the city of strasbourg could soon be
home to the largest
mosque in europe it's being constructed
right here
but before the roof is even on its mired
and controversy
that's after a grant worth 2.5 million
euros was approved by the local
authorities
to a muslim group behind the mosque the
brawling then began
the interior minister hit out at
strasbourg officials
saying that they were assisting with
foreign
interference the green city hall of
strasbourg finance is a mosque supported
by a federation which refused to sign
the charter of principles of islam
in france and which defends a political
islam
he's now ordered the state prefect to
oppose that multi-million euros subsidy
to the mili gorus islamic confederation
the group japan european movement
for the turkish diaspora says it's
dumbfounded by the rao
i think that it is a controversy that is
totally political
and it's hard for us to understand the
why and the how
how a french association a european one
which works here in france by the laws
of france
that makes it difficult to understand
the fury that has erupted
the organization which is said to have
close ties to ankara
has become a bet noir for president
macron
it was amongst three of the nine
branches of the french
islam council that refused to sign a
charter
renouncing political islam and
committing to french
values it's a charter that was not
discussed
not by the federation not by the mosques
and not by muslims it's a charter that
directly concerns muslims
and unfortunately muslims and mosques
didn't give their opinions
and that's not acceptable the issue at
hand though
isn't perhaps so much this mosque but
the wider current tensions between
france and turkey
the turkish president has repeatedly
lashed out at macron
accusing him of anti-muslim policies
in return macron has openly accused
turkey of getting ready
to meddle in next year's elections
there will be attempts at interference
in the next french presidential election
i consider this to be unacceptable
it's written down the threats are not
veiled
for most people here in strasbourg the
row has more of a political edge
and concerns about turkish interference
seemed
secondary the mayor of strasbourg
said if the government had information
they should give it to us
for me this is logical otherwise how are
we supposed to know if it's true or not
everyone has the right to their beliefs
whatever they are
christians muslims or jews i think that
we should also think about building
churches instead of criticizing things
i think as a muslim first of all to
finance a turkish association
to finance the mosque in the city i
think it is contradictory
i think it is a political decision more
than anything else
it has never posed a problem for
churches and so why does it pose a
problem for one mosque
so i think it is rather political
because it came without any warning
we know they were also the problems
between macron and erdogan recently
i wouldn't be surprised if there were
some shenanigans going on
and with the presidential elections only
a year away
some have suggested that the controversy
over this mosque
is being used as a bit of a diversion
tactic
over the government's handling of the
covid crisis
meanwhile the authorities in strasbourg
say the funding
is contingent on the miligaurus islamic
confederation reaffirming its commitment
to the values of the french republic
they've also complained directly to the
elysee
about the rao the minister of the
interior did not issue any warning on
this
subject the risk of foreign interference
should be addressed with precision
and seriousness dialogue with local
officials cannot be reduced to these
informal exchanges
but it wasn't just the interior minister
who hit
out at the decision to help fund the
mosque the minister for citizenship was
also scathing
suggesting the green party was on a very
slippery slope
and was flirting with radical islamists
that was a step too far for some
it is not possible today for the
minister to take advantage of his
position to demonize his opponents
perhaps because they are dynamic it is
the negation
of the democratic debate worse still
he said the mayor of strasbourg has
received death threats
since the controversy was unleashed what
this polemic highlights is how
heightened tensions are in france
particularly over
islam and islamic extremism as the
government tightens the screw on
any group or project that it thinks
could threaten french values
the more it's opening itself up to
allegations
of being anti-muslim charlotte dubinsky
rt strasbourg